IMMIGRATION AND THE WAR.
WE WILL BRING YOU PART TWO OF
OUR BLOCKBUSTER SWAMP WATCH ON
CHINA'S CORRUPT INFLUENCE
OPERATION WASHINGTON, D.C.
VERSE BACK TO THE ELITES.
TO ME, THE MOST IMPORTANT IS NOT
ACTUALLY THE ELITE.
YOU CAN BE PART OF THE ELITE AND
BE ON THE SIDE OF THE PEOPLE.
ELITISM IS AN IDEOLOGY THAT
PRIORITIZES THOSE AT THE TOP AND
BEING THE DOMINANT IDEOLOGY, BIG
PART OF THAT IS GLOBALISM.
THE IDEA WE SHOULD PUT BEG
NOTION OF THE GLOBAL INTEREST
AHEAD OF NATIONAL INTEREST.
THERE'S A STORY THIS WEEK THAT
IS A PERFECT ENCAPSULATION OF
GLOBAL THINKING.
IT WAS REPORTED THAT TECH GIANT,
GOOGLE IS WORKING WITH THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT TO DEVELOP A
SEARCH ENGINE THAT IMPLEMENTS
THE REGIME'S CENSORSHIP OF
INFORMATION IT DOESN'T LIKE.
THIS IS PART OF GOOGLE'S PLAN TO
GET BACK INTO CHINA AFTER PULLED
OUT IN 2010 IN PROTEST OF THE
GOVERNMENT HACKING OF GMAIL.
HUNGARIAN.
I KNOW ABOUT OPPRESSIVE
COMMUNIST REGIMES.
THAT IS WHAT TODAY'S TRAIN IS.
THE GOOGLE PART IS PERSONAL
BECAUSE MY WIFE ONCE WORKED
THERE.
WE HAVE A VERY COMFORTABLE LIFE
AS A RESULT.
SOME OF GOOGLE'S TOP EXECUTIVES
ARE CLOSE FRIENDS.
WHEN I THINK SOMETHING IS WRONG,
I WILL SAY SO.
THIS IS NOT JUST WRONG,
SHAMEFUL.
IT'S NOT THE WHOLE STORY ABOUT
GOOGLE, USE IT ALL THE TIME.
I'M SURE YOU DO TWO.
GOOGLE'S PRODUCTS ARE USEFUL
THAT'S WHY IT IS DRONE BIG.
BECAUSE IT GOT SO BIG, GOOGLE IS
NOT JUST USEFUL BUT DANGEROUS.
IT IS A LEADING FORCE FOR
ELITISM AND GLOBALISM.
IT IS GLOBALISM THAT BUSINESSES
MOST CORPORATIONS AMERICA REALLY
THANKS TO A PROGRAM RUN BY THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT?
GOOGLE WOULD NOT EXIST IF IT WAS
NOT FOR AMERICAN TAXPAYERS.
GOOGLE ONCE SAID THAT ITS
MISSION WAS TO ORGANIZE THE
WORLD'S INFORMATION AND MAKE IT
UNIVERSALLY ACCESSIBLE.
NOW, THEY HAVE FLOATED OFF IN A
GIANT BALLOON OF ARROGANCE.
UNTETHERED TO ANY NOTION OF
LOYALTY OR ETHICS.
GOOGLE IS HELPING AMERICA'S
NUMBER ONE ENEMY, THE EVIL
COMMUNIST DICTATORSHIP IN CHINA
TO DEPRESS ITS OWN PEOPLE.
THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF WHAT
GOOGLE ONCE DUKE FOUR.
GOOGLE HAS BUILT IN ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE INTEREST IN
BEIJING.
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE TO
ACHIEVE MILITARY DOMINANCE OVER
AMERICA.
ON TOP OF THAT, GOOGLE RECENTLY
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
WITH OUR GOVERNMENT TO DEFEND
DEMOCRACY, BUT IS FALLING OVER
ITSELF TO WORK FOR THE WORLD'S
WORST TO CRUSH DEMOCRACY.
TREASON IS BEING THROWN AROUND
TOO MUCH THESE DAYS, THAT SEEMS
LIKE A GOOD DEFINITION OF IT TO
ME.
THIS IS GOOGLE CEO, SOMEONE I
IF YOU GO THROUGH WITH THIS, IT
WILL SHOW THE WORLD THAT YOU NO
LONGER BELIEVE IN YOUR OWN
MISSION OF MAKING INFORMATION
AVAILABLE.
YOU JUST WANT TO MAKE MORE MONEY
AVAILABLE TO YOU.
IT WOULD EXPOSE ALL THOSE
SANCTIMONIOUS HIGH-MINDED TWEETS
AND STATEMENTS ABOUT HUMAN
RIGHTS IS STANDING UP FOR
DRIVEN BY ONE THING, MAXIMIZING
TO DEFEND YOURSELF.
PARTLY, YOU REFUSE TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE.
THERE'S ANOTHER REASON.
CHINA TOLD YOU NOT TO TALK ABOUT
IT.
YOU ARE NOT ONLY WORKING WITH
THE COMMUNIST DICTATORS TO
YOURSELF IN AMERICA.
IF YOU GO AHEAD WITH THIS I WILL
COME AFTER YOU EVERYTHING I HAVE
GOT AND I WON'T BE THE ONLY ONE.
THERE IS TIME TO CHANGE.
DON'T DO THIS.
DO THE RIGHT THING.
IN A PHRASE, DON'T BE EVIL.